we TV has put out a trailer for sex box
what is sex box Oh
take a look welcome to sex box now it
can take 30 minutes 40 minutes and for a
woman to be fully aroused feels like I
just lost my virginity to say yes to
sexual act with your partners to say yes
to love and say yes to commit all right
so to be clear in case you're not sure
what's happening there these people are
just having sex in the box there's no
camera in the box
there's no they're not we're not hearing
them we're not watching them have sex
they're just having sex in the box and
then they come out of the box and then
they talk about it with you know some
therapists there's a podcaster they'll
probably throw some comedians on there
this just seems so silly to me like we
live in an age where I don't know if you
know this but there is porn on there's a
lot of nudity out there the idea that
they'd have a show where then you're not
even watching it I when I first saw this
when our producer said this to me about
alright well the idea that you know you
of therapist or something
would watch people have sex and then
they'd all analyzed it that actually
seems sort of interesting to me the idea
that they're just having sex in there
and then they come out and talk about it
I mean this just seems this just seems
so backwards to sort of the progress
we've made in terms of sexual freedom
and and these figma ties enough that we
do in the bedroom and all that even
beyond that like I don't understand how
this is good television like you're
saying this was a rich on weed TV it was
a British show first yeah and it didn't
do well there why are we adapting it for
American television cause like it had
horrible ratings there nobody watched it
this reminds me so much of that black
mirror episode right yeah we talked
about black yeah
the one where the guy has to pay 15
million Oh is the first one in the list
yeah first so I didn't see that one yeah
it's just like yeah like the lengths
that people will go to for a sense of
like validation in their lives like I'm
gonna go have sex in a box on TV yeah
sure
but doesn't a show like this now in 2015
the way sex has changed because of the
internet the way we can talk about it
and the things that we can see doesn't
this just seem absurd like to me if this
was 2004 and this show came out I think
maybe there would be something to it you
know it may be but now we're just so
past the point and it's all so silly
like it's just silly to be talking like
you well you had sex you don't need to
cut you know like yeah I think that's
just like anything else any other
reality TV it's kind of engineered
conflict I'm assuming that the casting
is gonna be based on cut because these
are couples they're not even like two
random people having sex it's like
people who have sex all the time now
they're gonna have sex in this box so I
think that the idea is there gonna be
cash that's a great point because that
that would be another that would be an
interesting idea for just random people
random people having sex and then yeah
but the idea that it's just like couples
I think they're probably going to cast
for couples with like [ __ ] up problems
they're gonna cast for a woman who's
afraid that he's been cheating they're
gonna cast for a couple who's been
having sexual problems so then they but
then that's just depressing and also I
have a real problem I do a lot of
edutainment television yeah that's you
know what I pay the bills with and so
and a lot of times they put that under
the banner of reality so I meet with
people at production companies and net
networks and we talk about reality TV
and my one thing that I always say is
that I don't do humiliation television
just as a general rule I would never be
involved in a television show where
that's the focus yeah that's what I call
it and this to me is pure and and you
know unbridled humiliation television
yeah that's getting into the [ __ ] up
lives of people and so that you can feel
better about your own situation that's
that's why people enjoy this kind of
probably control for performance anxiety
because I would imagine like a major
factor yeah well I guess that would be
more of a factor if people were actually
watching you but again there's no
cameras in the box yeah you know
people sitting right outside the Sun
waiting for you to finish I guess you
match the next show is going to be like
pee in a urinal
[Laughter]
I can't pee you guys are watching me
yeah I get that I've got turn the faucet
on get you weird you get weird in the
bathroom but we do have a rash of these
shows right like there's dating naked
and naked and afraid' which I actually
think is pretty pretty decent but again
it's this weird thing with sex that
seems so it just seemed so immature to
me
oh this show would never do well in like
France or Germany or play people in
commercials right Big Damn boy isn't it
we still women's entertainment or is
that been read I think they've rebranded
like 18 times over yeah it's like TLC
it's like no longer you don't learn
anyway whatever write you down with sex
in a box let us know in the comments
right down below
[Music]